welcome to this video playing see you at
seven gather kind of its I've played
this guy before and his basic strategy
was just to shuffle around with no idea
whatsoever so this is this kind of
opening fits let em go perfectly and so
let's see what is what is coming up with
oh it's doing something that's
surprising so let's see how he plays
this now yeah the capture on d5 is is
just a mistake to be honest so let's get
right to punishment mode for Queen g3
mmm 23 what are you doing
it doesn't need a good buddy so we had
to give up the Queen they're quite
quickly let's see that we play this
correctly is getting c5 I could
sacrifice on f2 which I don't think that
this is helping me a lot so probably
taking here 95 and then move the Queen I
guess it's probably and probably the
best you still have to win yay with
Queen against or is it two minor pieces
and so rookie aight i guess and for we
should be 295 is also also a good idea
let's get this night into the game
okay I've been trading it's not a bad
idea okay so rupee for maybe and
centralizing detecting the bishop I can
take f4 here it's that good it's not bad
let's let's put it like that it's not
bad not not necessary either
hmm
okay so take f4 hmm yeah it's again not
bad but it's no particular reason to
give up material him
h5 h4 is also also an idea okay
ok that is loose pieces loose can be too
maybe simply on yeah I guess can be too
okay so Quincy five trips that's right
quite resigned yeah let the opening I
don't know and okay you can play the
Kali of course but here this is already
not so great because that isolated queen
form position is pretty good for black I
have the knight on f6 already and whites
position is somewhat wrong here with the
bishop I mean it's not it is not so bad
as it as it was after h3 h3 is just a
blunder and because of that typical move
that's some well-known motif that you
cannot play that and well he got
punished very swiftly yeah if white
takes him check check check and take
that one that's one point yeah and the
other point is exactly what happened and
white yeah white could resign I mean DP
continued but the position is of course
completely winning for black and maybe I
had some quicker way but well you are
Queen up so trading some stuff is it's
not not bad at all white in this opening
you shouldn't take here but think about
most like Queenie to this is pretty
pretty okay for white like has various
ideas age six for example of b6 but why
should keep that tension in the center a
little bit also I mean not every black
player knows how to play this some some
cake or so and then you have a pretty
good position of the night x for example
but taking this just a bad move as we
have seen okay thanks for watching